As you can see, Dimple.js's API is much closer to
what the grammar of graphics specifies than d3 itself.
This is because Dimple.js exists at a higher level of abstraction than d3,
and since the grammar of graphics is at a little bit of
a higher level of abstraction as well.
Dimple happens to fit nicely with the grammar of graphics specification.
The first few lines of code here are simply standard JavaScript,
which set up the variables for the width, height, and margins of the chart.
As well as the d3 code, which append an SVG element on our page.
The declaration here to use strict let's the browser know that you
want to enforce a restricted subset of JavaScript within this function.
The most important feature of strict mode is that it forces the browser
to throw explicit errors anytime JavaScript might silently fail.
Similar to what we saw in the first lesson for HTML elements.
These lines of code simply tell the browser to find the body tag,
append a new SVG element, add appropriate attributes for
the width and the height and then add a group with class chart.
We haven't seen a group yet.
But all the group does is, groups the SVG and everything within it,
into a single element.
Think of this is as the same way as webpages often use div
tags to group common elements together, such as, paragraphs or side bars.